just let me say a few the key messages I
mean other people think that you still
have to wait for new brakes with
technology and I don't think that's the
case we have the existing technologies
but they have to break through and that
doesn't come by itself and uncle venture
gas and America was in big surprise to
everyone and say in the last decade but
the first pioneers were already out
there trying to develop the technology
in the 80s so it takes a few decades
about three decades for new technology
to really come through and that's a very
normal time span in the energy indices
industry to actually have new
technologies coming on stream to about
one percent market share when it
actually becomes competitive with
existing incumbents so bear the mind
three decades before it becomes
competitive another three decades before
it actually reaches a notch that's your
market share so it's a really internet
intergenerational game then the other
aspect is something about efficiency a
lot of policy is based on an efficiency
that we won't improve ciety gayest of
link building around fifteen percent of
the x 25 years but efficiency doesn't
come by itself it has his own dilemmas
policy dilemmas because you know who's
going to pay for it because if an end
consumers not to have the expectation
that end consumer price will
continuously rise why would invest now
upfront a lot of money to invest in
efficiency while government's normally
like to say that energy should be more
affordable and come cheaper every day
and here's kind of India kata me too to
breach another critical technology which
we have to really come to grips with
soon is carbon capture and sequestration
CCS read to decarbonize the power system
I'm afraid if you want a lower carbon
system you can't do without a
technological fix called carbon capture
and sequestration